Women often ask me if I have any extra tips for them,
especially if they're working in a situation
where they're presenting to a lot of men.
Here's my advice.
First thing,
stop separating the genders,
thinking that in some way you need to be different.
Your job as a woman
is the same job that they have as a man.
To showcase your confidence,
to showcase your uniqueness,
to show how you really feel
and make people understand what you're passionate about.
Some men sound high,
some women sound low.
Neither should alter their pitch
just to speak to the other.
You should work on the uniqueness
of showcasing your own strength,
your own power.
And confidently present you,
male or female,
to the people.
And when you are passionate and when you are powerful,
they will listen
and they won't care about the gender.